THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE SWING SPACE. I ASKED ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO COME
TO THE HEARING ROOM SO THAT WE
CAN BEGIN, JUST SO YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE, THAT IS
MEETING AT THE EXACT SAME TIME
THAT HAS TWO OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, ONE WHO IS CHAIRING
THAT COMMITTEE, AND WE HAVE,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT ARE
PRESENTING BILLS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR
CHRISTOPHER FOR, BEING SO PROMPT
AND BEING HERE BECAUSE IT GIVES
US THE ABILITY TO START THE
AGENDA. ALTHOUGH WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO TAKE A MOTION OR TO VOTE
ON THE ITEMS, AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS, WE HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM. SO WE
HAVE 46 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. ONLY ONE OF WHICH IS
ELIGIBLE. ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE
PASS MOTION. THE REMAINING ARE
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. WE
HAVE ONE SUSPENSE FILE BILL THAT
WILL HAVE A PRESENTATION, BUT
THE AUTHORS FOR THE REMAINING
SUSPENSE BILLS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION, WHICH MEANS THEY
WON'T BE HERE THIS MORNING. WE
WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC ON EACH AND EVERY
ITEM, EVEN IF THE AUTHOR HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION THÀNH. AS
USUAL, WE WILL EXTEND A COURTESY
TO ANY MEMBER SHOWING UP IN
PERSON AND ALLOW THEM TO PRESENT
THEIR BILL OUT OF AGENDA ORDER
AS THEY SHOW UP. BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESSES TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND
REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR COMMENTS. SO WE'RE GOING TO
JUMP RIGHT IN AND WE WILL START
WITH AB 805 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA WHO WHO, AS I SAID, HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY, JUST GIVE ME A SECOND
SO THAT.
WE JUST GO THROUGH IT. OKAY SO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES PRESENT
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 805? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB 805?
CHECKING IN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. DO YOU HAVE A FILE
ON THIS MEASURE? YES. GOOD
MORNING, MICHELLE PERRAULT,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CURRENTLY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL,
THE WATER BOARD DOES ESTIMATE
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS OF AN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT, BUT POTENTIALLY
IN THE LOW TO MID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO EVALUATE
AND IMPLEMENT THE ADMINISTRATOR
APPOINTMENTS. ADDITIONALLY, THEY
ALSO ESTIMATE THE FINANCIAL
COSTS FOR EACH ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICE WILL BE APPROXIMATELY
$1.2 MILLION, FROM THE CAA OVER
TWO YEARS, AND THIS ASSUMES TWO
APPOINTMENTS PER YEAR. SO
FINANCE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT TO
THE EXTENT THERE'S PRESSURE TO
ADD SYSTEMS MORE QUICKLY, THE
ESTIMATED COSTS COULD INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND LASTLY, WE
BELIEVE THE BILL IS A LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE. THE BOARD IS
CURRENTLY, IN THE PROCESS OF
COMPLETING A WATER A WASTEWATER
NEEDS ASSESSMENT, WHICH ASSESSES
THE BASELINE CONDITIONS OF THE
WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IDENTIFIES WASTEWATER CONCERNS.
SO THE ASSESSMENT ISN'T SUPPOSED
TO BE COMPLETED UNTIL 2027. AND
SO WE BELIEVE THAT CONSIDERATION
OF ITS FINDINGS IS PRUDENT.
PRIOR TO PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
COSTS AS PROPOSED IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR SATO, ANY
QUESTIONS? OKAY. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, A B WELL,
ACTUALLY, IT IS A SUSPENSE.
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
JUST, HOLD IT IN SUSPENSE, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO AB 1757 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO DIRECTLY TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1757?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1757. SEEING NO
TESTIMONY, WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ANY COMMENTS? NO FILE. VERY
GOOD. ANY COMMENTS? SEEING NO
COMMENTS BY THE COMMITTEE, WE
WILL HOLD THIS OPEN UNTIL WE
HAVE A QUORUM. MOVING ON TO AB
1866 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART HAS WAIVED.
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 1866? WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
1866. A BILL TO ADDRESS A
LOOMING FISCAL BOMBSHELL AND
CREATE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
FOR TRANSITIONING WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES WHILE FIGHTING THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. FOREGONE FEES
WILL BE RECOUPED UNDER THE NEW
FRAMEWORK, WHICH ADDRESSES A
PROJECTED $21 BILLION FISCAL
RISK. OPERATORS ARE LEGALLY AND
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE TO PLUG
THEIR WELLS AND RESTORE WELL
SITES, BUT HAVEN'T SET ASIDE THE
NECESSARY FUNDS TO DO SO.
INDUSTRY BONDS COVER LESS THAN
1. THIS LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
SPENT AT LEAST 100 MILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
INDUSTRY CLEANUP OBLIGATIONS. IF
COMPANIES BANKRUPT OR EVADE
THEIR DUTIES, BILLIONS FALL TO
THE PUBLIC EACH YEAR. WE FAIL TO
ACT, INCREASES THE TOTAL COST
AND FISCAL RISK. CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY IN 2020, ALLOWING IT
TO WIPE 4.4 BILLION IN DEBT FROM
ITS BOOKS. THE COMPANY WAS
SADDLED WITH THE DEBT AFTER IT
WAS SPUN OFF FROM OCCIDENTAL
PETROLEUM, WHICH LEFT THE STATE
YEARS AGO WITHOUT PLUGGING ITS
OLD WELLS. IF THE MERGER WITH
AERA ENERGY GOES THROUGH CRC
WILL OWN ROUGHLY 40% OF ALL
UNPLUGGED OIL WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ELIMINATES
THE COST TO PROCESS, ANALYZE,
AND ENFORCE THE PEACE. THE FEE
SYSTEM. IT DECREASES INSPECTION,
TESTING, MONITORING AND
REGULATING COSTS AS IDLE WELL
NUMBERS DECLINE, IT ENDS THE
STATUS QUO INCENTIVE FOR
COMPANIES TO CHOOSE A MINOR FEE
TO AVOID AND ULTIMATELY DUMP THE
GREATER COST OF CLEANUP ON
TAXPAYERS, PLACING THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN WHERE IT BELONGS ON THE
POLLUTERS WHO CREATED AND
PROFITED FROM THIS MESS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. NO
TESTIMONY, JUST A PUBLIC
COMMENT. SAVANNAH JORGENSEN, ON
BEHALF OF THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CURRENTLY
HAS AN OPPOSED POSITION ON THIS
BILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES UNKNOWN, BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS OF
THE LEGAL SERVICES REVOLVING
FUND ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS FOR ANTICIPATED
ENFORCEMENT WORK. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE DOJ DOES BILL ITS
CLIENT AGENCIES, MEANING THESE
COSTS COULD BE RECOVERED.
HOWEVER, THE GEOLOGIC ENERGY
MANAGEMENT DIVISION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION ALSO
ESTIMATES IT WOULD REQUIRE EIGHT
POSITIONS AT $1.73 MILLION FROM
THE OIL, GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND AND THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION,
AND 1.64 MILLION FROM THE OGA.
ONGOING TO COVER THE WORKLOAD OF
THE ADDITIONAL REVIEWS,
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES. ADDITIONALLY, CAL
GEM DOES ESTIMATE APPROXIMATELY
$1.6 MILLION IN LOST ANNUAL IDLE
WELL FEE REVENUES DEPOSITED INTO
THE FUND SO THAT WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THEY ALSO MAY INCUR UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
LEGAL COSTS, DEPENDING ON THE
EXTENT OF THE ADDITIONAL DOJ
LEGAL SERVICES THAT IT MAY
REQUIRE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
COMMENTS AND NO COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SO AGAIN, WE WILL
PUT THIS, ON HOLD FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB. FOUR 2407 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HART HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2407? ANYBODY HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, ANY FINAL
ALL RIGHT, NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, WE WILL PUT THAT.
WHAT DO WE CALL IT YET? WE'RE
JUST HOLDING IT OPEN, TRYING TO
FIGURE N WHAT WE
WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING WITH
IT. WE'LL JUST HOLD IT OPEN,
WHEN NEXT, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO AB 1863 68 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANY
WITNESS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1868?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 1868?
SEEING NEITHER. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ. THERE IS NO
FILE AND THERE'S NO COMMENT FROM
THE COMMITTEE, SO WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN. MOVING ON TO AB 2290
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, WHO
AGAIN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO 2290? MOVING ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANY
COMMENTS? NO. PHÐ NO COMMENTS.
NONE FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN. MOVING ON
TO AB 1899 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1899? ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1899. MOVING OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO
FILE. THERE IS NO COMMENT ON
THAT ONE. SO AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE. SO
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN AS WELL. AB
1926 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. ANY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1926? ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1926. CHECKING
IN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ. VERY GOOD. AND
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
EITHER. HOLD. WE WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN. AB 2196 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. IS THERE ANY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION? IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 2196? ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2196? MOVING ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOFA. OKIE DOKE AND NO COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE EITHER. WE'LL
HOLD THAT ONE OPEN AS WELL. AB
1970 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
TODAY. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1970? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. MOVING ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, NØ
PHÐ. NO COMMENT ON THAT FILE AS
WELL AND NO COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AB 1975 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANY ANYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1975?
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JOLIE ONODERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? AB
1975 DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO
FILE. VERY GOOD. AND NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AS WELL. SO
WE WILL HOLD THAT FILE OPEN AS
WELL. AB 2786 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
AS WELL. AND SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF 2786
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THÀNH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE
AND NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL. SO WE'LL HOLD
THAT ONE OPEN. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US IS PRESENT.
SO WE'LL CALL HER FILE OUT OF
ORDER, WHICH IS AB 2364,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM. AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. BUT YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT THIS MORNING.
WE'LL JUST HOLD IT OPEN UNTIL WE
GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS. AB 2364
WOULD LIMIT DANGEROUSLY HIGH
WORKLOADS IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
CREATES A SEVEN PERSON ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING
STANDARDS IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY. THESE REGULATIONS
ADDRESSING WORKPLACE INJURIES
COULD SAVE SIGNIFICANT COSTS BY
REDUCING MEDICAL EXPENSES,
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS AND
LOST PRODUCTIVITY DUE TO
ABSENTEEISM. HERE, TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, I HAVE
RENEE BALADO WITH BAILADO
STRATEGIES, REPRESENTING SEIU.
VERY GOOD, LET'S CHECK IN THIS
AGAIN IS APPROPRIATION. SO IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING RELATIVE TO
THE COST THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. I'LL JUST SAY MY
NAME. RENEE BALADO, REPRESENTING
SEIU CALIFORNIA, THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL, AND I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. WE APPRECIATE
IT. IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2364? ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FILE QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. NO QUESTIONS. SO
WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIME COMES. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO OUR AGENDA
. AND NEXT UP IS AB 1976 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1976? CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? HOW ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? NO FILE
AND NO COMMENTS FROM OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB 2365 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY, WHO AGAIN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 26, 23,
65? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
WELCOME, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATT KATO. I'M THE
SENIOR POLICY SENIOR FELLOW IN
PUBLIC POLICY WITH THE AMERICAN
KRATOM ASSOCIATION. WE'RE THE
LARGEST CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUP
IN THE COUNTRY. HAVING HELPED TO
PASS 13, KRATOM CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACTS IN THE STATES.
14TH IS RHODE ISLAND, PREVIOUSLY
BANNED? THERE IS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THIS WEEK. WE
ARE OPPOSED CURRENTLY TO THE
LANGUAGE OF AB 2365 BECAUSE THE
COST OF THIS REGULATORY SCHEME
THAT'S CONTEMPLATED IN THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN ONE OF TWO
OUTCOMES. ONE IS THE PRODUCT
REGISTRATION FEES, WHICH WE
SUPPORT SHOULD BE BORNE BY
MANUFACTURERS, WILL BE SO
ONEROUSLY HIGH THAT IT WILL
BECOME ANTI-COMPETITIVE, OR IT
WOULD IMPOSE A BURDEN ON
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS IN ORDER TO
FUND THIS OVERREGULATION BASED
ON THE CURRENT LANGUAGE. IT
WOULD. SECONDLY, IT RESULT IN A
DRAMATIC REDUCTION IN PRODUCT
AVAILABILITY BECAUSE THOSE FEES
WOULD BAR MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO CURRENTLY PRODUCE SAFE, HIGH
QUALITY KRATOM PRODUCTS FROM
BEING ABLE TO ENTER THE
MARKETPLACE. IN COLORADO,
GOVERNOR POLIS REJECTED A
SIMILAR REGULATORY SCHEME,
SAYING THAT IT WOULD INTERFERE
WITH THE RIGHTS OF INDIVIDUAL
KRATOM CONSUMERS TO HAVE ACCESS
IN FLORIDA. IN A SIMILAR
REGULATORY SCHEME THAT WAS JUST
PROPOSED IN THE FIRST YEAR, THE
PRODUCT REGISTRATION FEES WOULD
BE $10,500 PER PRODUCT. IN THE
SECOND YEAR, IT WOULD BE $7,000.
THAT WOULD REDUCE CONSUMER
ACCESS OR BE ANTI-COMPETITIVE,
AND ELIMINATE MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES FROM THE MARKETPLACE.
IN THE STATE OF UTAH, WHERE THIS
LAW, WHAT WE CALL THE KRATOM
CONSUMER PROTECTION ACT, HAS
SAFELY PROTECTED CONSUMERS FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS. THE
REGISTRATION FEES ARE ONLY $240
AND RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS PAY
BETWEEN 150 AND $750 PER
REGISTRANT BASED ON SIZE AND THE
NUMBER, THE SIZE OF LOCATION,
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES. THAT'S A
MORE RATIONAL WAY OF DOING THIS.
EVEN THE GLOBAL KRATOM
COALITION, THAT IS A MANUFACTURE
WAS GROUP THAT SUPPORTS THIS
ADMITS THAT IT WILL BE AT LEAST
$1,700 PER REGISTRANT. AND THAT
IS, OF COURSE, GROSSLY
UNDERSTATED BECAUSE WE KNOW,
BASED ON THE EVIDENCE AND DATA
THAT IT WILL BE MUCH HIGHER THAN
THAT. SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
WHEN IT COMES BEFORE YOU. THANK.
VERY GOOD. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NO FURTHER
COMMENTS? NÓ. FILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD. AND
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. MOVING ON TO AB 1997
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON.
MCKINNON BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES AND IN SUPPORT. HOW
ABOUT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
. BRINGING IT BACK TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NÓ FILE. AND THERE'S
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL. SO WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
IT OPEN. AB 3127 AGAIN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ABOUT IN OPPOSITION. MY
NAME IS HILARY LARKIN. I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EXAMINERS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE 200 MEDICAL
EXAMINERS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO IPV VICTIMS,
WHAT I'D LIKE TO BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION IS A UC
SAN DIEGO REPORT ON THE COST OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS PUBLISHED IN
MAY OF 24, I DON'T WANT TO. I
MEAN, I'M GOING TO GIVE IT TO
YOU TO READ, BUT THE OVERALL IS
THERE $73 BILLION ANNUALLY COST
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
VICTIMS OF IPV, $88,000 PER
VICTIM AND $600 MILLION ANNUALLY
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FATALITY.
THIS BILL WILL NOT IMPACT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NUMBER OF CASES REPORTED MAY
BE DECREASED, WHICH MAY MAKE
EVERYONE FEEL BETTER, BUT REALLY
IS PUSHING VICTIMS BACK INTO THE
SHADOW. IT'S RELIEVING HEALTH
CARE OF ANY RESPONSIBILITY OF
IDENTIFYING AND REPORTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, AND JUST
ROLLING BACK ANOTHER SAFETY NET,
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS ACROSS THE
STATE. THE BILL ALSO WANTS TO
REPLACE LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH
ADVOCACY, BUT DOES NOTHING TO
SHORE UP THE FRAGILE, FUNDING
SUPPORT FOR ADVOCACY THAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW. SO VERY DIFFICULT TO
ADD ADVOCACY BACK WHEN WE
ALREADY DON'T HAVE A COMPLETE
AND AVAILABLE ADVOCACY GROUP TO
REPLACE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
FUTURE. WE HAVE PRESENTED
ALTERNATIVES WHICH WOULD BE A
MORE NUANCED, APPROACH, BUT SO
FAR, WE'VE COME TO KNOW,
AGREEMENT WITH THE AUTHORS. WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS IS
THE WORK WE DO ON THE GROUND
EVERY DAY, AND WE URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. VERY GOOD. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? CAN I
PROVIDE THIS TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU, MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
WINTERS HALL. I AM A FORENSIC
NURSE, EXAMINER, REGISTERED
NURSE AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE.
MOST DAYS I'M IN SCRUBS AND IT
SAYS FORENSIC NURSE. I TAKE CARE
OF PATIENTS EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT ARE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIME. THAT IS MY NORMAL JOB, I
WORK FOR ENLOE MEDICAL CENTER, A
RURAL, NONPROFIT LEVEL TWO
TRAUMA CENTER IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIANS. AB 3127
ADVOCATES FOR A WARM HANDOFF TO
ADVOCATES IN LIEU OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE DO NOT HAVE A
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER. WE DO
NOT HAVE A FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER. WE DO NOT HAVE A CHILD
ABUSE CENTER. WE DO NOT HAVE
RESOURCES FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE HAVE ONE DUAL CERTIFIED
AGENCY FOR DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY OR FUNDING TO RESPOND
TO THE HOSPITAL. NOW, FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AS
THEY COME FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT,
BUT THEY JUST STARTED PROVIDING
SERVICES TO US FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
BEFORE THAT, FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS, WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
THESE EXAMS BY OURSELVES ALONE
WITH THESE PATIENTS. THERE'S
NOTHING UP THERE. THIS BILL WILL
DEVASTATE OUR RESOURCES. LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS THE COUPONS FOR
THE PATIENTS TO GET THE HOTELS.
WE DON'T HAVE SHELTER SPACE FOR
PATIENTS. OUR HOSPITALS, SMALL
AND RURAL AND WE'RE THE LEVEL
TWO TRAUMA CENTER WITH TWO
HELICOPTERS. AND THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS GOING TO DO TO US.
PATIENTS WILL DIE FURTHER MORE,
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A TERRIBLE
FISCAL IMPACT, IMPACT ON SEXUAL
ASSAULT FORENSIC EXAM TEAMS
THROUGH OUT THE STATE. THE PENAL
CODE IS VERY CLEAR. FORENSIC
EXAM TEAMS ARE TO BUILD LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR FORENSIC MEDICAL
EXAMS, AND LAW ENFORCEMENT IS TO
REIMBURSE US. AND THEN THEY
APPLY TO CAL OES FOR
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THEIR STREAM.
THIS IS ALL BASED ON EITHER A
LAW ENFORCEMENT CASE NUMBER OR A
HEALTH CARE MANDATED CASE
NUMBER. HEALTH CARE. HEALTH CARE
MANDATED REPORT CASE NUMBER. THE
PATIENT DOES NOT HAVE TO ENGAGE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO GET A
FORENSIC MEDICAL EXAM. WE JUST
FIXED THAT A FEW YEARS AGO. BUT
WE HAVE TO MANDATE THE REPORT.
THAT'S HOW I GET THE CASE
NUMBER. I ASSIGN THAT I GIVE THE
PATIENT THE EXAM. THE PATIENT
DOESN'T HAVE TO TALK TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THEY GET THEIR
EVIDENCE COLLECTED, THEY CAN GO
HOME. WE GIVE THEM THE
INFORMATION TO CONTACT ADVOCACY.
IF THAT'S THEIR CHOICE AND
RESOURCES. BUT, THEY HAVE A
CHOICE TO WAIT AND DECIDE. DO I
WANT TO REPORT LATER? DO I WANT
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THIS?
MEANWHILE, THE EVIDENCE THAT
WE'VE COLLECTED, BECAUSE IT
RAPIDLY DEGRADES, HAS A CASE
NUMBER ASSIGNED TO IT, GOES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, GETS BOOKED
INTO EVIDENCE, GETS PROCESSED BY
THE CRIME LAB, AND THEN THE
PATIENT CAN MAKE UP THEIR MIND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE READY TO
ENGAGE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. IF
WE TAKE THAT MANDATED CASE
NUMBER AWAY, THERE IS NOTHING
FOR ME TO ASSIGN THE EVIDENCE
TO. THERE IS NO WAY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BOOK THE EVIDENCE
INTO CUSTODY. THERE'S NOTHING
FOR THE CRIME LAB TO RUN. WE
HAVE RAPID DNA SERVICE NOW. THEY
DO IT ON BASED ON A CASE NUMBER.
SO WE GET PAID. THE HOSPITAL
GETS PAID BASED ON THAT CASE
NUMBER, AND THE EVIDENCE IS
BASED ON THAT CASE NUMBER. IF WE
TAKE LAW ENFORCEMENT OUT OF THIS
EQUATION BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
PENAL CODE IS RIGHT NOW,
PATIENTS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE FORENSIC EXAMS.
THIS CREATES A GIANT MESS FOR
US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT DETAILED TESTIMONY. IT'S
VERY HELPFUL. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NØ FILE. GOOD QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. NONE, WE'LL
HOLD THAT FILE. OPEN WHEN WE
TILL WE GET A, A QUORUM. MOVING
ON TO A B 2043 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BERNER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BERNER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2043? HOW ABOUT AN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NÓ PHÐ.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
EITHER. WE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AB 2259 AGAIN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERNER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS OPPOSED
TO AB 2259 AT THIS TIME, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY DOES EXPECT A CONTRACT
OUT THE WORKLOAD FOR THE
CREATION OF THE HANDBOOK AND HAS
SUGGESTED THAT THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL MIGHT ASSIST. CHP
ESTIMATES THAT COSTS OF ABOUT
$28,000 FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT TO CREATE THE HANDBOOK
ON BEHALF OF CALSTAR, FINANCE
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A FISCAL PRESSURE ON THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT, WHICH IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT, AND BASED
UPON MOST RECENT PROJECTIONS,
THE RESERVES IN THE MVA MAY BE
EXHAUSTED BY THE END OF 2526. WE
WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT
BECAUSE THE BILL IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE, AND THIS FUNDING
WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE LATEST
BUDGET PLAN, THE SEPTEMBER
DEADLINE IS NOT FEASIBLE. VERY
GOOD. BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SO WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THAT OPEN. WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB
2063 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NØ PHÐ.
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE, SO WE WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN. AB 2739 AGAIN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF HIS BILL?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
PERMANENT FINANCE? NO FILE. VERY
GOOD. THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE EITHER. AND
SO WE'LL HOLD THAT, AB 2739
OPEN. MOVING ON TO AB 2887 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. VERY GOOD. NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
EITHER. SO WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AB 2971 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCINI, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. AND NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
EITHER. WE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AB 2071 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CARRILLO. JUAN CARRILLO IS
THERE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. AND THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO AB 2097 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CURRENTLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL. THE BILL
WOULD CREATE COST PRESSURES OF
BETWEEN 50 AND $73 MILLION
ONGOING UNDER PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND, THE REQUIREMENT TO
OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL MUST BE
CONSIDERED IN CONTEXT OF
COMPETING BUDGETARY PRIORITIES
AND UNCERTAIN FUTURE GENERAL
FUND REVENUES, PARTICULARLY IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL ENVIRONMENT.
WE WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT THE
BILL CREATES A SINGLE ONE OFF
COURSE OFFERING REQUIREMENT,
WHICH MAY CREATE PRESSURE TO ADD
ADDITIONAL COURSES IN THE
FUTURE. AND UNDER CURRENT LAW,
IF AN LÀ CONSIDERS THE COMPUTER
COMPUTER SCIENCE SUBJECT MATTER
PRIORITY FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS, THEY MAY UTILIZE THEIR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO
SUPPORT THOSE COURSE OFFERINGS.
VERY GOOD. NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND SO WE WILL HOLD
THAT FILE OPEN AB 2458 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
AND AGAIN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HI,
VALERIE JOHNSON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YES. THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CURRENTLY HAS A OPPOSE ON THIS
BILL. WE WOULD JUST INDICATE
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DOES INDICATE ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS OF $6.2
MILLION TO ESTIMATE AND ADJUST
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
INFORMATION FOR STUDENT PARENTS
AND TO UPDATE THEIR DATA
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
WITH ONE TIME PROP 98 GENERAL
FUND COSTS RANGING FROM 1.1
MILLION TO 2 MILLION, AND
ONGOING PROP 98 GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY 1.2
MILLION FOR COLLEGES TO ESTIMATE
AND ADJUST THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR STUDENT PARENTS
AND TO UPDATE THEIR MANAGEMENT,
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALSO INDICATED ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF 150,000,
AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
IN THE RANGE OF 30 TO 56,000, TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL. VERY GOOD, BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THERE'S NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SO WE WILL THAT WILL
REMAIN OPEN AS WELL. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON IN THE AGENDA TO AB
2229 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON HAS. COME
BACK TO IT WHEN THEY SHOW UP.
OKAY. SO, WE HAVE A BILL RIGHT
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON'S BILL, WHICH IS A
LOWENTHAL BILL WHO, THE AUTHOR,
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS NOT HERE,
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO JUMP OVER
IT AND WAIT FOR HIM TO SHOW UP.
THAT IS THE ONE Dð PASS
RECOMMENDATION, AGAIN, WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE DO WANT TO
HEAR FROM HIM AS WELL. SO WE'RE
JUST GOING TO HOLD THAT OPEN
UNTIL HE ARRIVES. MOVING ON TO
AB 2229 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, IS THERE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF HER BILL? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL,
AS THE BILL WOULD LIKELY CREATE
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
THAT COULD BE IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FROM PROPOSITION 98. GENERAL
FUND BY REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTIONS ON MENSTRUAL HEALTH
AS PART OF SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION, WE WOULD NOTE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY CURRENTLY
PROVIDE INSTRUCTION ON MENTAL
HEALTH AS PART OF THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION, AND IT DOES EXISTING
LAW DOES AUTHORIZE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE, AGE APPROPRIATE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION FOR K-12
PUPILS, AND REQUIRES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH AND
HIV PREVENTION EDUCATION,
INCLUDING INFORMATION ON HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT. VERY GOOD, THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE, HOLD THAT OPEN.
MOVE ON TO AB 2349 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. AGAIN, IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT, ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION,
BRING IT BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NÓ FILE. VERY GOOD.
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THAT OPEN AS WELL. WE'RE
MOVING ON TO AB 2278 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY
. IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
2278? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NØ FILE. VERY GOOD.
AND THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS REGARDING THIS RIGHT
NOW. SO WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN. AB
2285 BY ASSEMBLYMAN MEMBER
RENDON WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
, ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? YES. CURRENTLY,
FINANCE WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH
THE BILL DOES NOT. I'M SORRY.
LET ME START OVER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL CURRENTLY,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH DOES
NOT ESTABLISH ANY NEW OR
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY WORKLOAD
REQUIREMENTS BY CODIFYING THE
LIST OF PRIORITIES AND GOALS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PUBLISHED IN THE OUTDOORS FOR
ALL INITIATIVE IN NOVEMBER 2023,
IT DOES CREATE IMPLEMENTATION
EXPECTATIONS THAT COULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. VERY GOOD.
BRINGING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS, SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
AB 2373 AGAIN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RENDON, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NØ FILE.
VERY GOOD TURN. I THOUGHT ALL
THESE PEOPLE WERE GOING TO
TESTIFY. I HAD HIGH EXPECTATIONS
AS MOVING ON TO AB 2289 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2289? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL.
HOWEVER, WHILE THE DMV WAS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE AN ESTIMATE
FOR THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE NEEDED, IT
CHANGES RELATED TO THE BILL,
FINANCE DOES ESTIMATE THAT
ADDING THIS SCOPE TO THE
EXISTING DISPLACED, OR, I'M
SORRY, DISABLED PLACARD. IT
SOFTWARE COULD RESULT IN COSTS
OF UP TO $2 MILLION, THEREBY
INCREASING THE FISCAL PRESSURES
ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
AGAIN, WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT, AND AS OF
THE MAY REVISION, THE RESERVES
IN THAT FUND ARE PROJECTED TO BE
EXHAUSTED BY THE END OF 20 2526.
VERY GOOD, SEEING NO COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AB 2295 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FILE NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE AS WELL. SO
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN. AB 2961 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE. SO WE WILL HOLD
AB 2961 OPEN AB 2333 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
COFFEE. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. VERY GOOD. I
THINK WE SCARED EVERYBODY OFF.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS SOMETHING WE
SAID. THEY SAY, NO, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT JOB. IT'S
REALLY. I KNOW. WELL, IT'S THEY
SAID IT'S REALLY BORING. OKAY.
AB 20 2348 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. IS THERE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? I WILL. HOW ABOUT AN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NÓ FILE. WE WILL HOLD THAT OPEN.
MOVING ON TO. WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD AB 2364. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO AB 2395 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? I'M SORRY. I WAS
HOPING TO TESTIFY ON 2364. IF
POSSIBLE, WE'LL ALLOW YOU TO DO
THAT. WE ALREADY TOOK THAT UP,
BUT, YOU'RE HERE, SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MUCH
APPRECIATED, JOE DEVINE WITH
PLATINUM ADVISORS HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO 23, 64 ON BEHALF
OF ABM, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS SO MUCH. APPRECIATE IT.
BACK BACK TO AB 2395 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA WHO IS
WAIVED. PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO. FILE AND NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE'LL MOVE ON. WE'LL
HOLD THAT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO AB
2471 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
PATTERSON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE WILL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
TULARE AND HUMBOLDT, BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION
? SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO FINANCE, YES. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CURRENTLY HAS A
NEUTRAL POSITION ON THIS BILL,
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSES
DOES ESTIMATE THE BILL WILL
RESULT IN AN ABSORBABLE
REDUCTION IN REVENUE OF 1.313
MILLION OUT OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING NURSING FUND
IN 24, 25 AND 2.625 MILLION IN
25, 26 AND ONGOING. THE BOARD
DOES NOTE THAT THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 42,000 PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES THAT PAY THE EXISTING
$125 RENEWAL FEE BI ANNUALLY,
AND THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING FUND CURRENTLY HAS A
PROJECTED ENDING FUND BALANCE OF
$32 MILLION IN 2324 AND CAN
ABSORB THIS REDUCTION IN
REVENUES. VERY GOOD SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, WE WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN. MOVE ON TO AB 2669 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. WILL CHECK AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
VERY GOOD. THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AB 2701 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÆ
VALLAPUDUA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÆ
VALLAPUDUA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILE.
VERY GOOD. AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SO WE WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO AB 20 2840.
2842 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NØ FILE. VERY GOOD.
AND SEEING NO COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS. AB 3074 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SCHIAVO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
HER BILL? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. VERY GOOD. AND
SEEING? NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE, WE'LL HOLD
IT OPEN. AB 3142 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE. NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN. AB 3162 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. YES. HELLO, CHAIR
NICHOLAS SCOTT. AND ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
AND ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND'S
PROUD CO-SPONSORS, I JUST WANT
TO MENTION IN THE ANALYSIS, THE
DEPARTMENT SAID THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE DIFFICULTY ENFORCING, BUT
THERE ARE BECAUSE OF NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THE ORIGIN
OF THE SEAFOOD WOULD COME FROM.
BUT THERE ARE USDA LABELING
REQUIREMENT S THAT REQUIRE
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN AND TO LABEL
WHETHER THE FISH WAS FARMED OR
NATURALLY CAUGHT, WHICH WOULD, I
THINK, HANDLE THAT ISSUE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HI, JONATHAN GILMORE
AND MY PERSONAL CAPACITY. I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE IT. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CURRENTLY
HAS AN OPPOSED POSITION ON THE
BILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE DOES INDICATE UNKNOWN
COSTS. AND WE WOULD NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THE AVERAGE
COST OF ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
ILLICIT TRAPPING AND MARINE
WATERS IS BETWEEN 6000 TO
$27,000 PER INSTANCE. EXCUSE ME.
CREATING A POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURE TO THE
GENERAL FUND, DEPENDING ON THE
FREQUENCY ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES, WE ARE OPPOSED
BECAUSE THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES AGAINST FARMED
OCTOPUS, WHICH IS
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM WILD
CAUGHT OCTOPUS, CREATES UNKNOWN
AND POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE FACING A
$46.8 BILLION SHORTFALL FOR THE
2425 FISCAL YEAR, THE GENERAL
FUND WOULD BE SORRY.
ADDITIONALLY, THERE'S NO FUNDING
THAT IS CURRENTLY IDENTIFIED
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE BUDGET TO
SUPPORT THE ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
AND THE GENERAL FUND IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE FUND SOURCE IN THIS
INSTANCE BECAUSE WITHOUT A
REGULATED AQUACULTURE FRAMEWORK,
NO PERMIT OR SALES REVENUES CAN
BE COLLECTED TO SUPPORT
ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS, WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN
AND WE'LL GO BACK TO. AB 2105 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL.
WELCOME JUST SO YOU KNOW, WE, WE
LACK A QUORUM RIGHT NOW. THERE
IS A DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
YOUR BILL, WHEN WE GET A QUORUM,
WILL WILL TAKE UP A MOTION. BUT.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE, WE'RE HEARING
AB 2105 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. APPRECIATE THAT. AND
MEMBERS VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 2105, WHICH REQUIRES A HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN, CONTRACT OR
HEALTH INSURANCE POLICY ISSUED,
AMENDED OR RENEWED ON OR AFTER
JANUARY 1ST, 2125 TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR TREATMENT OF
PEDIATRIC AUTOIMMUNE
NEUROPSYCHIATRIC DISORDER
ASSOCIATED WITH STREP INFECTIONS
OR PANDAS AND PEDIATRIC ACUTE
ONSET NEUROPSYCHIATRIC SYNDROME
SYNDROME OR PANS, DESCRIBED OR
ORDERED BY A PHYSICIAN OR
SURGEON, AS DEFINED BY CURRENT
CLINICAL PRACTICE GUIDELINES
PUBLISHED IN PEER REVIEWED
MEDICAL LITERATURE OR PUT FORTH
BY ORGANIZATIONS COMPOSED OF
EXPERTS TREATING CLINICIANS
EARLY AND EXPEDIENT ACCESS TO
THE TREATMENTS IS CRUCIAL TO THE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS OF PANDAS
AND PANS. IN ORDER TO AVOID THE
DEBILITATING SYMPTOMS.
POTENTIALLY PERMANENT
NEUROLOGICAL, NEUROLOGICAL
DAMAGE, AND SOMETIMES FATAL
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
DISORDERS. AB 20 105 WILL ENSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WHO ARE CONFRONTED WITH THESE
DISORDERS DO NOT EXPERIENCE
UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN TREATMENT
THAT CAN LEAD TO DISASTROUS
OUTCOMES. TRAGIC OUTCOMES AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS, ALL COSTS
IDENTIFIED BY AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS ARE MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE, AND CALPERS DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE A SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
IMPACT. THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES. RESPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. VERY GOOD. WE'LL
CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NO FILE. OKEY DOKE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE? WE
WISH WE HAD A REALLY
SCINTILLATING QUESTION, BUT DO
WE HAVE NONE? SO WE'LL ALLOW YOU
TO CONCLUDE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS I INDICATED, THERE IS A Dð
PASS RECOMMENDATION. WE'LL TAKE
THAT UP WHEN WE GET A QUORUM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST, AB 3196 BY STEPHANIE
NGUYEN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE
WILL CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THÀNH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE? NO FILE, NO COMMENT
FROM THE FINANCE, QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE, WE WILL HOLD THAT
FILE OPEN AS WELL. SO OUR WORK
IS DONE HERE TODAY, OTHER THAN
TO GET THE REST OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SHOW UP SO WE CAN
TAKE SOME MOTIONS. AND. WELL, I
NEED EVERYBODY IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO FINISH UP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO EVERYBODY WHO IS,
IS HERE WHO JOINED US TODAY AND
WHO TESTIFIED AND THOSE WHO
JOINED US AND WERE WERE
LEARNING, I GUESS, APPRECIATE
THEM AS WELL. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A VERY SHORT RECESS SO WE
CAN GET THE REST OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE.
COMMITTEE, WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER, AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THE ROLL. PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL.
HERE. CAVERO. HERE. JONES. ASHBY
HERE. ASHBY. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
BECKER. HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
HERE. CIERTO. CIERTO HERE. WAHAB
ALL RIGHT. SO WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS GO THROUGH. WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE ENTIRE AGENDA. SO
WE'RE WE NEED MOTIONS. WE CAN
JUST DO THAT AND PASS. AND THEN.
SO WE'RE BACK IN SESSION. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP. WE HAD ONE
BILL THAT WAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AND THAT'S A B
2105 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL TO HAVE A MOTION. SO
MOVED THERE IS A MOTION MADE.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE
FIVE ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5
TO 0. AND IF I FAIL TO REPORT
BEFORE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. SO
THAT'S WHY WE CAN TAKE A VOTE ON
THE BILL. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON, AND START WITH AB 805 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA, THAT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, IT WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1757 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. THAT BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. AB 1866 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HEART. IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION IT WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2407 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HEART. IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO AB 2407 WILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 1868 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. IT IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 1868 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2290 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 2290 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1899 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES. IT IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 1899 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1926 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 1926 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2196 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY IS A IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB 2196 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1970 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1970 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1975 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. IT IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1975 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2786 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2786 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 1976 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HANEY IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1976 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2365 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HANEY IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2365 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 1997 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNEY IS THE
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1997 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 3127 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNEY IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3126 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. 2131 27 AB
2043 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2340. 2043
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2259 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2259 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2063 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2063 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2739 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2739 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2887 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2887 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2971 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION IT WILL. AB 2971 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2071 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2071 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2097 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2097 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2458 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS THE
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2458 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2229 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2229 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2349 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2349 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2278 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2278 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2280 85 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RENDON IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2285 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2373 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2373 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2289 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2289 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB AB 2295 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ADDIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2295 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2961 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2961 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2333 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2333 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2348 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
2348 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2364 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF
US IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE,
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2364
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2395
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2395 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2471 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM PATTERSON IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2471 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 2669 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TÍNH IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2669 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2701 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VÆ VALLAPUDUA IS THE
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 2701 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. AB 2842 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPPIN IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB 2842 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB FOR AB 3074 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIAVO IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB 3074 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
AB 3142 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
3142 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
3162 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3162 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE, AND AB 3196 IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3196 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. THANKS. ALL
RIGHTY THEN. LOOKS LIKE WE ARE
FINALLY DONE. THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY, FOR BEING PROMPT AND
BEING HERE TO TESTIFY, THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.